und für 5 Monate machen Sie einfach zu
die Bahn als zuständiges
Eisenbahninfrastrukturunternehmen wird
zu machen und da wird es entscheidend
darauf ankommen damit wir die Kundinnen
Kunden nicht verlieren dass es ein gut
funktionierenden Schienenersatzverkehr
gibt und Umleitungsstrecken für den
Güterverkehr also
Ärger ist vorprogrammiert ist klar und
trotzdem machen 45 Orten in Deutschland
zur Sanierung dieses Netzes keine
Alternative weil heute die Zahl der
Störungen in Stellwerken ja am Gleisbau
in der Oberleitung ein Signalen so
häufig ungeplant zufällig auftreten dass
immer mehr Ressourcen in trouble
Management trappelshooting gesteckt
werden muss und da ist wie ein Haus im
Privatbereich die Generation notwendig
[Musik]